So get up on my
What are you doing? Oh, please don't grab me. Please don't grab
me. I want to go live in the Middle East. I will gladly give
up my streaming career. I will give up my streaming career. I
will wear a Nika. >> Why lie about this? >> I will
wear. >> I'm going to need you not to attack any of the
contestants. >> I need you to not play with my addiction.
I'm already giving up gambling to be in this house. And now I
am sitting here with these people and I'm in a small room and
I'm getting >> Why were you on your phone looking at posts
and pictures and stuff?
>> Uh yeah, that was my bad. So they posted
>> I told him to wait that. >> How hard is it to
communicate that? I just My mind is blown. I just don't know
how that's hard to communicate.
So, if you guys don't know, Sam Pepper decided to start his own
version of Fish Tank. Okay. And Murk and Wes are both on it.
MK and Wes are both there. I'm psyched. I have not built up any
sort of like what we call it like narrative around this yet.
So, I I've got a bunch of clips. Maybe we'll start watching a
little bit more on stream, but it's Yeah, Murk and Wes, by the
way, are both in this house. Uh, as is
Mike Smalls Jr., okay, the guy from the hurricane in Miami, Mike
Smalls Jr., He is also in the house. All right,
let's watch Sam kicking it off and explaining it to everybody.
>> Watching the big brother on kick inside this house.
And I'm going to give you a quick tour. If you want to apply,
click the link below. Anyone's welcome to apply. So, let's go.
We'll go this way. And like I said,
>> what does MK even bring entertainment wise? Uh, spragging
the out all the time. Just constantly spragging out. uh being
willing to get violent with people, being willing to assault
people, being willing to commit crimes on camera. That is what
Murk brings in terms of entertainment. They're doing a house
tour and then uh Sam talked about possible contestants. Okay.
>> Are you going to narrow? >> We We have the idea.
Okay, we know the idea. You got a house cammed up. We don't need
the whole thing. All right. >> Put it down. >> The
audio Well, what you guys have to remember is these guys also
all run their own streams, I think. Or at least Murk runs her
own stream a bunch of the time. I know a bunch of the clips,
excuse me, are from MK's stream. to say 20 more or less at some
point and then do like a one-on-one interview with each to get
a good feel for their
>> Maybe something like that. >> So far off of the
list, who I'm most interested in off of the list. Merc off the
perk cuz she's a character that I don't really know much about.
I think she's like a strong female character. Maybe that Maddie
chick cuz she looks like she would be nuts. But I don't think
I put Adriana in. If I put Maddie in, I think I have to put Maddie
or Adriana. I can't put them both in. I kind of like the idea
of Wes BTW being in the house. I think Wes is a character that
we've not seen in the community much. And I think he could be
really funny in the house. Yeah. So, with the Who do you want
in as guys chat? Who do you want to be in the house as guys?
What guys would you choose? Wes, Modin, Morat, DBR.
Okay. Wes, Modí, Morat, DVR. Let me just ask you one thing. I
put four desirable girls in that people would want to Right.
I put four desirable girls in that people would want to out of
West Modí,
uh, Morat, and DVR.
Which one of them are they going to want to? None of them. There's
going to be no
It's just four smelly guys and then in >> what I was thinking
right was Tazo
Crazy Tan.
Okay. Slum G and and it's Sam or whatever his name is.
What I was thinking was I was thinking Duran
Joel Tam
and Korean man going on as well. There's a clip from two days
ago right here.
>> Wes. Turns out Wes not a huge fan of Mercur right off
the bat. Okay. Wes Wes came into this house and he was like,
"Yeah, I hate this person." >> I can see him doing
>> trying to get like a deck of cards or
leave the house.
>> Why are you stealing my
>> Well, let's see how this resolves.
>> She wants you to sit by her and raise
>> Am I crazy? Oh, close left menu. Sure. Am I crazy or
would Wes just sit here for like his entire life until she reacts
in some way?
>> On the moon landing. We never went to the moon.
>> Stanley Cub
to do this warehouse
>> because it was much more beneficial to just say we went
during the space race.
>> I guess >> no, I'm not scared. I just need to
>> Cope. Cope. I'm not scared. I just need to readjust.
Cope.
>> I just want to be so close to you. It's kind of crazy.
>> Are you a fan? >> You can just say you're a fan.
>> You don't have a crash out.
>> You didn't get angry. No one would watch. Longer I sit
here, the less angry you get. the less viewers you have. >> Oh,
really? Cuz I'm getting more. As as the time goes on, I get more.
>> I'm not done streaming, you [__] >> Go
stream. >> Go stream. >> No, I want you to have your
little fun, your little viewership. >> I thought I don't
get I thought I don't get viewers because I'm >> I'm the
one they know I'm
just paying. >> Oh, don't know. Don't know. >> Reuben
donated $3.
Jesus, AIDS is really taking its toll on that guy. He's melting
away before our eyes. AIDS is terrifying. Okay. AIDS is terrifying.
I will never a lady boy in Thailand without a condom. Okay. Wes
has taught me the way. That's just that's that's a way to that's
a way to end it all. Okay. He's melting away before our eyes.
>> Just crash.
>> All you got to do is have >> the only one crashing
out is you,
>> Yeah. No problem. >> Well, clearly you're going
to stand here and sit there do nothing but you know. I'm not
doing it, right?
>> I don't know why I'm racist there,
>> Give it to the white man to say he wants to put a black
woman in
>> Bro, there's no way they just sit here like silently
for very long, right? >> Okay. Something happens. Jesus.
Never mind. He like I don't I don't >> This is actually
for a while. Hold on. We might have to >> might have to
find the next clip. Hold
>> Thank you.
>> Oh, are we going to have
>> Okay, this this is working now. This is working now.
For whatever reason, it's working. It's fine. It's not going
to crash. It's not going to crash. This is like day three. You're
missing a lot of content. Oh, Junar Arc, I love that you just
volunteered to go grab all of the first 3 days of content and
link them to me. I really appreciate you, buddy. Thank you. >> Oh,
I'm sorry.
how the [__] >> doesn't he usually pay to lay
>> Can we get your uh BJ BJ >> like this? >> I
mean, what's
I'm sorry.
I thought I thought you knew that. >> [__]
me. [__] >> Flashing something. God damn it.
It won't lock in.
If I ever see it in If I ever see you on the streets,
>> oh, by the way, Wes, I I don't know if Wes ever puts
a shirt on for this entire 3, four days that's gone. So far,
I don't think Wes has put a shirt on at
>> Look how you [__] >> What's the context
for the staring? Wes hates MC.
I'm going to have like
that's what we got here. I'm I'm >> I'm say it again. >> Right.
If I ever see L on the street, you want to block. You know what
I'm
>> All right. So, I'm going to approach
>> Luka, what's the
damn car? >> Yeah. What the is going to lock it like that?
You know what I'm saying?
I love that I have my
>> I'm sorry.
>> I'm skipping like 30 seconds at a time. >> I know.
>> Oh, he's breaking a little bit.
>> Leave the address. Oh yeah.
>> I can't wait to deny it or something.
>> You're not going to go home.
>> Well, I'm going home with something fart or burp in
her face.
>> They said I look like
my head.
>> Yeah. See, and Sam just lets the
>> He's breaking her. And Sam just lets Sam just lets the
stuff happen. >> Yeah. I mean, cuz I'm next to you.
technically, I'm a big tech. Maybe I should tweet about how
it is. >> Maybe after I can
>> Don't care.
>> Where's your
That's why I'm using my second because I don't have chat. >> Oh
my. And she also crash now because
>> Yeah, I have.
>> Is that true that you were her was like a lot? Is that
true? She was fast. >> No, you're truly unable. >> Did
she like herself? >> Very young.
>> I was so nice to her, bro. I was so nice. You guys see
six people at her asking one person. It was not >> a couple
days ago.
everything she had and then she backstabbed me and you didn't
sleep that
right here. I'm fine.
>> This is okay. I've got uh
nothing but hatred for the the kick clips. Hold on. This a merk
clip
just going down the stairs.
Because I'm a pizza party.
You are
>> Did she just grab like some sauce off the top of the
pizzas and put it in the entertainment stand?
>> Was this like guacamole or something?
have a pizza party.
>> She grabs whatever this is
>> and she walks it over to the entertainment stand and
puts it in the entertainment stand.
doing here, I guess.
Is that what I'm sensing? Wait, what is this? Murk finds out
that Wes's HIV and her reaction go to 2 hours 4530. >> I
don't understand how you don't learn the language.
>> It's not even
>> 4 days ago, by the way. >> Oh, that's right. You
do have HIV. >> I do have HIV. >> Wait, are you talking
about that? >> No. Are you serious? >> Hold on. >> Are
you genu?
Okay, so Wes basically pranked everyone saying that he has a
>> and made like a fake document
>> better. There was a uh >> he says he faked it.
I don't think he's that good an actor. I think he didn't fake
it. I think he really has AIDS. And the prank is actually telling
people he does have AIDS. >> An experimental drug that
I found in Germany that I got shipped to Thailand. >> Does
it reduce
it? >> I tested for 6 months. I'm not even considering
he's such a troll.
>> It's It's
No. >> No. I I No, I'm sorry. She's throwing me
>> I don't I don't care. I don't care.
>> Uh Merks never heard about Magic Johnson. Okay. Don't
you guys remember Magic Johnson? They they like wouldn't let
they didn't know if they could let Magic Johnson play basketball.
Turns out that guy had AIDS. He I don't know what happened. He's
just never gone. He's been fine. All right. But also, he was
allowed to play basketball. You can't spread AIDS very easily.
Okay. >> I do not care. That's disgusting. I don't care.
STD as you guys know,
you do not
>> Do you understand,
bro? I have to literally cut you open. >> I don't care.
Listen, I literally cannot hide. It's impossible. >> I
don't care. >> I don't even care. >> The medicine
killed this
little travel [__]
lecture someone that's not okay with [__] like that.
Like, do not lecture me because it's like, you can't trans. I
don't care. I'm saying I don't have HIV
>> Okay. I'm just person on the joke. So, this is at Sam's
house. I don't know if it's at Sam's house exactly or if it's
just some random house apparently in the Philippines. Not in
Thailand, guys. Or no, sorry, that's Sam's in the Philippines.
This might be in Thailand. The house is probably in Thailand.
I don't know if we'll see Sam go there. >> Look how she
moved away.
>> I'm going to do whatever the [__] I want
to do. This is my >> uh J.R., can you just add timestamps
to your links?
So, you can just go right here. There's this little button right
here. You hit share. You go start at this time. You can add the
time stamps yourself. Bing bingo bango. Okay.
>> It's just better if I have to reopen it cuz the tabs
crash. Then it's just better to have the time stamp there and
not have to scan each time. Thank you.
>> The virus is dead. It's not unattelling
up for him, bro.
>> I I changed the SD results to say positive and >> Wes
had been losing a lot of weight. I'm not going to lie. It feels
like he's kind of stalled in his progress. Okay. He was losing
a weight and now I don't know what happened. He was like losing
so much and it's like kind of slowed down it seems like. Well,
let me see here. 1 hour 22 to 1 hour 30. I might be able to just
click through to this Junar Arc. This one kind of loaded for
me. It seems like going 1 hour 22 to 1 hour
or 1 hour 13 up to 1 hour 22. Hour 13. >> Let me run this
[__] out real quick. >> What's my >> Wait,
is hard 1K? I'll drop 49 of them right now.
>> I don't care.
>> He's so obese. >> How much? Who? At least I'm
not a racist skeleton crackle. >> I'm racist. Yeah.
You got >> I said
what? Yeah. [__] black people. People
>> I swear to God this will stop crashing soon. I swear.
I swear.
>> Okay, this worked. This worked. This >> Hey, West.
>> Here we go. >> Um, I got >> They got a big
problem with Wes, by the way. Okay, for content, there's a big
problem. Sam's about to break >> a message from my uh I'm
like I'm paying like $7,000
this month for like clippers to clip this event. And also like
Kick has like this um clipping server with like an unlimited
budget and we've got like an influx of uh clippers messaging
us saying all of our clips are getting rejected on Tik Tok because
you with your top off look like women's. I'm I'm I'm actually
not joking. So, all of the clips are getting rejected and shadowbanned
on Tik Tok because the algorithm thinks you're a woman walking
around with the out.
>> Is it okay if I get Peggy to drop you some t-shirts?
>> No, you don't want to the game. I'm not playing your
game. >> All right. Thanks so much. >> Based, let's
go. [__] your 7K, Sam. You
>> You love to see it. You love to see it.
No, this is the AIDS clip. This is the AIDS clip. Where we at
here? I actually don't know where we're at. Let me see where
Jay Dog Arc was at with the links. Uh, let's see here. Hopefully
this one works. Oh, I had closed the other one too early, didn't
I? >> I'm just wait. You're so scared your >> I just
shut off like half of my extensions. So, hopefully this works.
>> Hey, there's money behind Yo, there's money behind here.
>> That might be from the previous uh
>> Yeah, look at Wes going for it. Yeah. So he can pay
for more of his riddled >> Oh, by the way, you uh guess
what? This is you cutting me. I have HIV, which means you could
have cut me over. >> No, you scratched me. Blood was drawn.
>> I'm cool. >> Yeah, that's how you get >> That's
how you HIV, you [__] >> No, I didn't scratch.
>> That's literally how it works. You opened a wound. If
you haven't opened that, if you open any on your >> Yeah.
So, I did all of them. Great. Play-Doh man.
>> Cuz she went and ducked my [__] >> No,
I didn't dig nothing. I lifted it up gently and nearly.
>> Oh [__] Soapbox Society with the five gifted.
Let's go. That's a 3042. We are $3, guys. $3. Any donation away
from another hour on the stream. Let's go. We got We got clips
for the rest of the night. We've got content for the rest of
the night. We will be covering the kick.
>> So, you admit you have HIV?
>> So, you
So, you admit you have HIV? >> I do. >> Oh, so you're
admitting you have HIV? You just you might have contacted >> Oh,
so he admits now that he has HIV. You're disgusting, dude.
>> What the [__] >> Get him away.
>> Oh, wait. We can do this. >> There are lots of
clips in stream chat. I I looked a little bit. It didn't seem
like there's very much from the first two days.
>> We can do this, >> bro. Yeah, we can.
>> What's wrong? You're going to be in there for 5 minutes.
>> Okay, then stay up. Okay. >> Five minutes is the
maximum amount of time you would be. >> Okay. Well,
>> hello. That's Barbadoo with a gifted sub. That's another
hour. Let's go,
>> A rock surgeon with 10 gifted. That's actually two more
hours right there. >> Two hours. 26. Let's go, guys. 10
gifted from Rock Surgeon. Thank you very much, >> bro.
I'm going to bomb it and like [__] Sam for sending
me into a house with someone that has HIV and not disclosing
that. That's nice. >> They really they really think that
uh bless his HIV. Who paid for the house? It's Sam Pepper. Sam
Pepper's project. Sam Pepper's doing this for some kick content.
Okay, >> so yeah, let's let's get HIV and then ruin my
life. Yeah, that's that's real cool. I don't get
Bro, the fact that you're saying, "Oh, it's not AIDS." Bro, what?
Yeah. >> Oh, what's up? Stoked. Yeah, I'm stoked. Are you
a Wes viewer? Stoked. Is that you usually where you go? We did
host Wes the other day. Uh, I'm going to try to catch up on clips
today. Okay, we're catching up on basically everything. MC getting
uh very upset about Wes's AIDS. >> you guys are insane.
See, this is what's I want to go live in the Middle East. I will
gladly give up my streaming career. I will give up my streaming
career. I will wear a na. >> Why lie about this? >> I
will wear burka. Whatever I need to wear, I don't care. I will.
I'm done with I'm done with Western culture. I'll give up drinking.
I'll give up everything. I'm >> She's kind of going east.
She's going like halfway. She's going to the Middle East. Okay.
Go Middle East, gentle lady. >> Going to live in the Middle
East. I want my husband to stone me or slap me across the face
if I get out of line. I don't want to drive. I don't want to
vote. I don't want to go to school. I will stay at home and take
care of the kids. I will give up everything. I'm going to the
middle I'm going to the Middle East. >> It's not as bad.
>> Just noticed that guy. >> Sam, you need to discuss
with him right now whether or not he actually has HIV.
I'm serious. If he has HIV, I am leaving. I need you to have
a discussion with him right now. Offstream. Serious.
I need to know. If he has HIV, I'm >> Yeah, this is a shocking
soap box. Murk Murk's kind of weird on stuff like that. Okay.
She went to vet school, so she probably has like some knowledge
and seemingly no knowledge of how AIDS
transmits. Underrated comment. Thank
>> because
because
I like to have
>> Yeah. And I have a proof. Like I I need
>> Sam's just saying 50/50 over and over >> I don't
know if you guys can see this. Okay. Sam's just sitting here
spamming 50/50. 50/50. Chance he's got AIDS. Okay.
Extremely relevant West clip to ask to ask you about. You know
who Destiny is? The streamer. >> Short guy. Looks like
a a goblin.
>> [__] you. Hey, blue politics girl. Oh, my
son called me a rapist on Twitter. Girl, that guy. >> How
about horse looper? >> Oh, horse is a lot more. >> It's
too big. >> Yeah, horse will [__] kill you,
bro. >> Too big. Yeah, >> horse, you're dead if you
[__] a horse. >> Yeah, I'm not small, but >> Destiny
is a pedophile now. Well, that's
>> That's about the exact way I expected him to take that.
Right. I I'm sorry. Wes is just like he's already
Wait, that was unrelated. I'm sorry. That is funny though. Well,
that's news.
That's That's exactly how I expected him to take that. I That's
not shocking at all. Right. Wes knew that he wasn't a good person.
Wes Wes West. Yep. He knew >> he's [__] with
me.
>> I don't I think he thinks I'm playing. I think he thinks
that I'm willing to like I'm serious.
>> Oh sh Okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold on,
guys. Okay, we'll finish this and then I got to go back to
we're going to have to go back to the chorus stuff. Okay, I don't
know if you guys are if everybody who's here now remembers us
going through the chorus stuff, but we will have to go back through
some of that cuz Taylor Lorenz has tweeted and she's actually
gotten the stamp of approval from
a massive politics influencer and it's not Hassan. We'll cover
that right away. 4 minutes. I'm just going to get a joint here
real quick.
>> Get on the thing, dude.
Yo, quit playing with me, bro. Quit. Get on the microphone.
>> Hello.
Yo.
>> Bro,
Sam.
>> Hello. Can you hear me?
>> Does he have Bro, please don't. Please. Does he have
HIV, bro?
>> Dude, what?
>> She's actually like in a corner crying about it right
now.
>> Did you?
>> She's so fake.
>> I mean,
Well, you need you need No, Sam, I'm telling you. >> I'm
pouring myself a drink. I'm locked >> Talk to him. If he
is positive, like I I need like this is something that should
have been figured out before like all this happened because it's
a health risk. This is not okay. So, I need you to talk to him
if he has
>> I don't have any clips unfortunately of this from uh
the kick from the house point of view. >> I didn't scratch
him. I touched his. You should have watched Wes's Gigachad entrance.
Send a clip.
>> So, so >> I scratched his stomach. >> So,
you're >> dude, you can hear his laugh. You can hear that.
That was him.
>> You can hear his fluting laughter. >> Telling
me I touched his stomach.
>> So, so go away. So you're telling me so instead of getting
rid of the person >> in stream chat? Where in stream chat?
I don't see it.
You just you say in stream chat. I don't see it in stream chat
>> That has HIV.
Oh, just don't touch people. Okay. Got it. Got it.
Got it. Tell me. Stay. I'm going to stay the away from me. >> Oh,
okay. 1 hour 57. I got you. I got you. I see it.
1 hour 57. We're supposed to watch Wes's entrances from four
days ago. There you
Swear to cop my
took my vape. Is nothing sanctimonious in this world anymore?
>> Sacred? Is nothing sacred? Lots of things are sancty.
>> [__] you. >> Get me in. Hey, you [__]
>> And he didn't put a shirt on for the rest of the time
he was in the house.
Guess what? Didn't even pack shirts. Okay, that was the only
shirt he brought with him and he just tore it off.
>> By the way, Jakun Arc, I realized you're telling me
that as if it's a fact. Now, I just said that because it was
obvious in the way he tore that shirt off that he was not going
to be wearing shirts while he was here. I just immediately riffed
that because it was obvious that's where this was going. Okay,
>> never mind.
>> Who are you? Who are you?
>> Oh, what's up you?
>> Hell yeah.
>> the energy
>> contagious only doing good.
>> Sam up hereing
chair. Headphones.
>> Headphones. Headphones. Headphones.
>> Okay, hold on. I hear you. Hello,
>> West. It's a lot of energy for you to be exerting this
early on.
There's something I have. It's called stamina. Okay. When I was
420 lbs, I went from having sex in 3 minutes to being 26 lbs,
having sex for 40 minutes. All right. There's nothing in here
I would [__] yet. So, I got to expend this energy
somehow, buddy. >> Minus 500 for taking his time. >> You're
saying that you you're saying that you would not you would not
Moxy.
>> Who's Moxy? >> The blonde chick.
>> If I was into
bounce chicks, maybe. That looks like you gave a down syndrome
woman a makeover.
like she has some weird niche on only fans that goes nuts for
her. But yeah, she's mentally challenged. I don't think legally
you can have sex with her >> and what
people maybe not in Thailand, but in the US I'm pretty sure there's
>> qu level before you can consent to >> who have
you met before.
>> Wes is like Wes is like too powerful for this niche
of people. Like these people do this content cuz they really
don't have a lot of other options. Wes is like actually funny
and he does this kind of content because he has no self-control.
So it like it's actually the perfect
>> none of them. >> I thought the black guy was the
baby. I thought you had a celebrity. I was like, "Holy [__]
the budget's going nuts,
>> I literally thought it was the baby. I'm not exaggerating.
That's not racism. He just looks like the baby. He has the same
outfit,
same swagger.
>> Okay. And um and like what how are you how do you have
like a game plan in here at all? I mean
talk do you know who the baby is? No. Wait I know I know he's
a rapper. I know a little bit about the baby because the baby
didn't the baby somebody in a Walmart. Isn't there a Dave Chappelle
special comedy special about the baby somebody in a Walmart?
That's exactly how I know who that is by the way. Unless he shot
somebody in a Walmart because he's the guy from the Dave. Okay.
All right. The baby. The baby. That's how Dave Chappelle says
it. The baby. Okay. Rapper shot somebody in Walmart. Uh, I just
want to point out I got that 100% right off the bat. This is
all you need to know about the baby.
What? Huh?
Rare insults. Head built like a PT 06 PT cruiser. Okay. Okay.
Okay. That's the baby. Jesus Christ.
>> You don't I'm going to expect >> I don't even
know how the show works. There's like so many fernology jokes
and racist jokes there that I just can't possibly worst shower
of all time. You believe you didn't tell us anything. You said
I broke this [__] >> Speaking of the baby and
AIDS, >> you didn't show up today with HIV, AIDS, any of
them deadly sexual implants, many diseases that make you die
2, 3 weeks. Put yourself on like the lady. If your smell like
water, put a cell phone on like the other, fellas. >> Lights
up, >> fellas. If you ain't sucking in the parking lot,
put your cell phone out. >> Let's be real about this [__]
>> Be [__] real. >> Some of y'all [__]
suspect as a Let's be real. >> I'll get somebody out here
a million dollars if they can guess who in here. >> I got
a million dollars right now. If you can guess who? File stunner.
Who you think?
Who?
>> I know who that is. I know who the [__]
that is. Let's go.
Let's go. I don't know who that is.
I don't I know who that is. I'm sorry. I do not know. It was
Tory Lanes. Oh
[__] I totally know who Tory Lanes is. Right. That's
the guy who shot Mag the Stallion, right? That's the guy.
Wait, no, he did. You're right. He didn't. They framed him. They
framed him cuz he was about to get his originals back. His uh
masters, right?
They framed him.
No, they framed him cuz he was about to get his masters back
for all of his uh all of his music. Okay,
that's what I remember. Torlane shot Klay Thompson's girlfriend.
Okay.
>> I don't know about that. Listen, I'm going to go back
to what I know best. Okay. What? Where my wheelhouse is? Fat
white guys
for days, bro. Oh, by the way, you can win 50k. I couldn't hear
the [__] It's already down to 49,000. How did How
is that even [__] legal? The whole goddamn show doesn't
even start. There's not even eight people in the [__]
house and it's already been reduced by $1,000. [__]
you. >> Yeah. So about that. I was scared if I tell you
everything you might not come >> Okay. Here. Make a deal.
You that $850 cuz that's already locked up. I'll take the $850
pack of cigarettes or a vape. >> All right. Okay. We'll
get to your We'll get to the negotiations. >> You want
content, you got to keep the bear happy. You feed the bear salmon,
the bear will continue to play and scratch the pole and rub its
back on the tree. But if you don't let the bear play, it's going
to have a [__] mental breakdown and start hurting
people. I don't know if you've seen the rest of these contestants.
I'm not real athletic specimens. I may not look like much, but
I'm a powerhouse. I'm Eddie >> What? Mike Smalls is a strong
guy. A very serious cheat month. >> I'm going to need you
not to attack any of the contestants. >> I need you to
not play with my addiction. I'm already giving up gambling to
be in this house. I've been thinking about Kino. I've been hearing
the [__] ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding in my ears since I left my house. I lost $5,000 right
before I got here. I'm a little on edge. I had to give my vape
to some mentally challenged guy in the hotel who could barely
speak English and now I am sitting here with these people and
I'm in a small room and I'm getting uncomfortable. Samuel, >> thank
you. >> It's a laptop. It's your laptop, Sam.
>> Don't touch the laptop. Kick that [__] laptop.
>> Don't touch that. That's Peggy's laptop. It's Peggy's
laptop. >> I would never do that to that girl. God, I miss
her sweet ass, >> bro. Okay, thank you. We're done here.
>> All right. No, I'm good. >> Okay. Bye-bye. Uh,
watching you back. >> Whatever link you just linked, that's
broken. That doesn't work. Good one, Kenny. All right. I can't
tell. Did JT talk give us another time stamp here? We got another
time stamp we're working with or what are we doing here? >> Oh,
wait. What? Getting like some stuff. I'm just looking for Do
we have additional time stamps? I don't think so. I think I'm
back to clips here. But I think what I'm going to do is go to
this uh this weird like nudes thing that happened. Okay, I think
I've got clips von Claus for this one. Give me a second. I think
we got clips von Claus. Let's check it out. Let's check it out.
this is a hard. >> So, this Indian guy apparently found
nudes of one of the women there and was sharing them around the
house uh very strangely. Let's check it out.
>> This guy,
>> you know her
krypto chick. >> It's a crypto chick. sweaters then push
I don't send me the lady wait
notes I'm just trolling chat
>> I laugh dude
>> what the is her >> Mhm. San
I don't know who this guy is. >> We just looking at stuff.
But listen, this all I'm going to say. There's a picture of a
character in the crib.
>> Wait, the indie guy shirt. No, really. I know it's of
the one girl, but
a little interesting there. So, I'm going to say it's a little
interesting. >> I don't like that. >> Yeah, a little
interesting. >> That was that was a little offp putting,
but I'll keep that between me and me and Shark. I have a clip
of Dora
showing of Dora showing
Mike Smalls other people's
>> they're in the house >> other people's news that
are in the house other people's news that are in the house what
makes it worse is >> is that were leaked when the when
the person in the house was
>> and he's going around showing people them in the house
>> um that's like a bit least
Uh, why did it have to be the Indian guy? Okay. Why Why is Sam
Pepper
making me racist and making everybody else racist? Okay, this
is [__] >> situation with someone in the house
and I wanted to hear what you want how you wanted me to hear
like deal with the situation.
Um,
>> it's a it's her nudes by the way. >> The
she's a who cares.
Uh, hero is
These are nudes from when she was a minor apparently.
That's a really weird attitude for you to take. Are you sure
you wouldn't rather go to destiny.gg and sign up for an account
there? That might be a more appropriate place for you to hang
out. Just saying. Just saying. Just saying. Maybe that's an maybe
that's a more appropriate location. Go ahead. >> The Shek
guy, Dora, I call him. She
um he there's clips of him number one on his phone, which he
shouldn't be. Um, but there's clips of him sharing like uh pictures
of you with like showing them to other people in the house. >> Uh,
obviously you know what I'm talking >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah,
I do. >> How How do you How do you want me to deal with
that? Because obviously I'm I'm I don't think that's like all
right. I don't think that's good at all. Um, I wanted to know
how you how you want me to deal with it. >> Yeah, that
sucks ass. Um, the only problem is that I asked him like I asked
him in the morning. And I was like, "Do you actually >> Hi,
Jtock. It's the girl who fell down the escalator. What's up,
Kinetic Kel? We just watched you. You You were on the stream
like 2 days ago. You fell down an escalator. How you feeling?
We watched the the skin peeled from your shin. It was up. It
was crazy. Ketic fell." Yeah, >> That like he started like
attacking me. He was like, "No, no, you should not say that."
Like he started like attacking. >> Hey, confirmed it's
her. Do you think there are a lot of people looking to impersonate
Kinetic Kel in a kick chat
Brazilian lad, is that your opinion? I literally said I'm going
to end up on a Jtock stream, aren't I? Yeah. Wait, why were you
hanging out with Zeus is actually a way better question?
Cuz Zeus was randomly there. What the Am I Am I insane or was
it not Zeus who was like pulling your [__] shin skin
off?
Am I hallucinating? She made the same KG fell joke in another
chat. It's her. Okay. Well, damn, they're in Vegas. I'm not tracking
this stuff that much. >> I don't know. Um, it's it's my
that I, you know, that I licked on internet sucks. I don't know.
Do you have any uh
>> This person like is so not phased by this, by the way.
>> I mean, I don't know. I just wanted to see like I wanted
to hear opinion of how you want to deal with it. >> It
sucks ass that he just like started attacking me when I asked
him because he's saying, "Yeah, bro. I saw it and like I'm a
gooner. Like I said something on my phone like I would be like
>> okay. Uh this Indian guy
this is literally he must be a DG. Okay.
He has the excuse down for why he has on his phone guys. I'm
just a gooner. I'm just a gooner. Guys I'm just a gooner. That's
gooner culture. Okay. We just keep child on our phones. All right.
>> Like okay. Yeah it's my fault because I have them you
know online. And I can't blame anybody for having
>> Sir, what if I told you that Steven Banell thinks I
am really smart and really good at storing images of
>> It's just the way I keep I don't know. >> Yeah,
I mean that's obviously and showing other housemates and stuff
like that. It's like it's completely irresponsible and
>> Do you know why you're here?
>> So I can stream my name out there. >> No. Do you
know why you're in the diary room right now? Why did I call you
in the diary room right now? >> To talk about the incident.
>> What? What happened? >> Very relevant clip. Hold
on. Very relevant clip.
>> Wait, hold on. Is this the same thing again? Using this
again. You know who Destiny is? >> God damn it. >> Short
guy looks like a goblin.
Send it real quick. >> Politics. Oh, my son called me right.
>> I'm going to watch this clip again. >> That guy.
>> How about horse looper? Oh, horse is a lot more. Yeah,
horse will [__] you,
>> horse, you're dead if you [__] a horse.
>> Yeah, I'm not small, but >> is a now Well, that's
news. >> And everyone stop.
>> Well, that's news.
>> American kiss soon or kissing? >> He want he want
to make with me content. But uh this guy, >> which one?
>> What kind of content? He wants to launch an only fans
with you. Like he he has said I can I can sit and he can test
my uh body. >> What the?
>> he can test your body. >> No, it's okay. It's
okay. I don't worry. >> what the >> yeah, this guy
had to go. Okay, I'm sorry. This guy had to go.
There's some weird This guy's a weirdo.
>> So, uh, while I was streaming, these guys were talking
about, you know, everyone. And, um, someone posted the photo
of her. Do you want me to show it or you already saw it,
>> bro? Okay. Number one, >> do you want me to show
you? Sam, I can I can show the stream. Sam, let me pull Let me
Let me show you exactly what we're dealing with here. >> Why
were you on your phone looking at posts and pictures and stuff?
>> Yeah, that was my bad. So, they posted
>> Listen, that was my bad. Uh, you see, my lawyer told
me I had to retain that
>> I clicked on it. It was about the Israeli flag. And
then they posted another link. I click on it. I asked, "Do you
know who this is? Is this the same crypto chick that he doesn't
know?" And I was the picture of What was the picture of? >> Oh,
the picture of her holding Israeli >> No, it wasn't. What
was the picture that you showed him? >> The first in the
clip. In the clip, what did you show him? Was it her with an
Israeli flag or was it a video or picture of her?
So it was >> No, it's not. So it was Was it her with the
flag or was it her? Was it her?
>> It was the link to her website. >> No. Was it
Did you show Mike a picture of her? Yes or no? >> To be
honest. To be honest,
nothing was shown. It was not. >> If it wasn't, then why
did Mike react to it and say, "Oh my god, that
>> Oh, I don't know. because she was the fact that you
No, no, no. I was going to I was going to give you a severe punishment.
I don't I don't think you knew she was picture by the way she
is. It's weird, bro. Not only that, not only that, the fact that
you're trying to act as if you didn't do it, it it makes it completely
unacceptable.
>> Bro, I did not expect like a kit bokit in the middle
of my kick house stream. We get a free kit boa skit. That's insane.
And it's going to it has to end now, Dora. It has to. You can't.
It It's You can't walk around the house. Okay, Dora. If there
was a picture of you as a 17-year-old boy that was on the depths
of the internet and someone had found that and posted it, would
you want people in the house just to pretend it didn't happen
and not look at it, or would you want them to put it up and show
other people in the house?
>> Okay. Before I >> No. Would you want them to do
it? Yes or >> That wouldn't be That wouldn't be nice. Yes,
it would be. No, it's not about being nice. It would be weird,
wouldn't >> Yes, but we we didn't know nothing about the
age. I was just asking like, you know, usually guys ask, you
know, and just the day before. >> It doesn't even if she
was 18 years old. Do you think it's weird that you got pictures
of a random girl you met that day of her and started showing
other people in the house? I'm not saying you knew her age. I'm
not saying you knew her age. This is incredibly culturally insensitive
from Sam here. Okay,
this guy, he's not a part of Western, dude. He's He's not sure
what's going on. Okay, Sam, can you be a little culturally sensitive
to this guy? What the [__] man? >> But I'm
saying, is that weird?
>> It is because
>> No, there's no ifs. There's no buts. Yes, it's weird.
That's the end of it. That's the sentence. Yes, it's weird. Like,
how how am how am I supposed to justify keeping you in the house
when you're doing [__] like that? That's weird. It
makes the event look bad. It makes me look bad and it's uncomfortable
for the girl that's now in the house with you who's been going
around showing creepy pictures of her.
>> It wasn't It wasn't pictures. It was a website link.
That's it. >> So, you're saying you showed Mike a URL?
A URL? tech >> a URL to which he responded, "What was it?
Why is her ass out? Why are her teeth out or something?" >> Like
he literally asked, right? >> And Mike went and Mike and
Mike went, >> "Oh, damn, bro. Oh my god. Is that the crypto
chick? Oh, damn, bro. What the are you saying? It was clearly
an image, a thumbnail, or a picture. What are you saying? You're
a You're a chronic liar. You have something wrong with you. You're
a chronic liar, bro. And I put so much faith in you being in
this house.
>> You out of every single person in this
>> This is not even a stereotype. Indians know a lot of
them. Don't know. A lot of them don't know basic manners. That's
actually what a stereotype literally is. Kenich one. Okay. Kenichwan.
That is literally a a stereotype. I know a lot of these guys.
This is not even a stereotype. Indians know a lot of them. that
don't a lot of them don't know basic manners.
>> you're the smallest person. You're the smallest one.
You're the smallest one, bro. I really gave you a chance and
it's
>> Sam, I I'm being honest with you. I clicked on the link.
I showed him. I was like, "Crypto chick. Yeah, that's it. We
did nothing else." And then we moved on from the conversation
and I showed the Israeli flag. That's it. I moved on from >> Bro,
there's no way India stands with Israel. Okay. India stands with
Israel. I knew that. I knew that >> conversation right
away. I had no bad intentions about it. It's just I was dumb
asking those things. That's it. I I I know it was stupid to do
it. I shouldn't have done that. I shouldn't have clicked on the
link. I shouldn't have shown it to >> every single time.
Do not touch Israel. Okay. Do not touch Israel. This is like
my favorite meme on the whole internet. Okay. Indian people just
love Israel. Okay. Israel's number one fans.
>> Donated $3. How ironic is it that the Indian guy cannot
be redeemed. >> Sir, please do not make these jokes.
Thank you for Thank you for the three, Ruben. Ruben, I appreciate
it. Okay, I appreciate you. >> It was stupid of me to do
it. I do stupid things,
but I had no bad intentions of, you know, watching the video
or spreading it around to anyone. No, that wasn't my intention.
>> It doesn't matter if you put up number one, you're not
meant to be on your phone. Number two, you're putting up random
people's you met that day. Yes, you don't know whether it was
a leaked thing. You don't know whether she was That's why you
shouldn't start showing people it. Maybe you should have took
her in private and said, "Hey, just to let you know, there's
a link being shared around about you. I I just showed people
an Israeli flag." I don't know why these exist. Okay. I don't
know. I don't I just I don't know. >> I just wanted to
tell you so you could take care of it. Maybe you can speak to
Sam. No, you didn't do that. You showed it in a gloating way
with a smile on your face and you and you showed it off to to
her. >> My intention wasn't to hurt anyone or nothing.
I showed it to him and we we moved to the next conversation right
>> It was about the other thing. That's it. And I showed
him other stuff from my thing and that's it. >> We we skipped
from that right away. And I didn't say nothing. I didn't react.
Nothing. And it was not his fault. It's not my fault that stuff
happened. And it >> All right. I've got to work out what
I'm going to do here. So, you can leave the diary room. >> Can
I? >> It's too much of a weird situation. I kind of like
have to do it. I kind of have to. It's got too many ifs and buts
and it's just too I I can't I can't really with that. And the
fact he's so unapologetic and doesn't really realize it and like
kind of worms his way out of it. I don't like that. I mean, he's
not even meant to be on his phone. If he just listened to me,
then there wouldn't be any issues. >> He's leaving. I hope
you will. It's better for you. I hope you
>> take care of >> 100 bucks for the hat. 100 bucks
for the
>> Peggy, I love you. I'm going miss you.
>> a Wes is shameless. Blast is so shaveless. Okay, hold
on. Clip of Murk getting trolled by the chat while she's sleeping.
I don't know what this is.
Sleeping here. Not literally sleeping.
>> That's a reasonable reaction. I Okay, then clip of M.
I'm guessing people can play TTS for some amount of money and
they're doing this to upset Murk explicitly. So, she's using
tampons for earplugs to avoid the TTS. Okay, these are tampons
along with the the eye cover. Tampons in her ears. Okay, creating
a perfect seal. Let a TTS play. Where's the TTS at? Come on.
Come on. We didn't get a TTS here. Okay, does this work? Watch
from this time stamp. Does it lay back down? Oh, hold on. We
get a TTS here. Hold on. Hold on. >> [__] shut
up. Uh,
[__] Oh, [__] your ear plugs. >> Oh,
did she win? They're spamming TTS. It's not effective.
>> Shut up. >> CPS better be at least $50 for sleep
deprivation torture. Well, I think it might be free. Seems like
they didn't get her. Okay. She actually she actually won. She
held out. She won in the end. All right. Uh is bad.
Let me see here. All right. Are we on to So I just did the I
just did the whole incident part. Okay.
We watch this different random altercation. I just got I've just
got different clips from all over the place now. Okay,
>> this is Mark going at Nelly for I don't know what possible
I don't know what reason exactly. Hold on so bad my dick.
What are you doing? Oh, please don't grab me. Please don't grab
me. Don't grab me with it. Please don't do it. Please don't do
it. Please.
>> Oh yeah, you're acting. Don't do it. Please don't move
this.
>> Dude, MC like Merc has like um what do you call it?
Like woman protection. Like no guy wants to get physical, right?
But she's way too big for most women to try to like contain in
any way. It's uh she's kind of got like she's just overmatched
for everybody. >> Oh my god. >> Is that Zeus?
>> I don't think so. >> Please don't grab me. Oh
my god. >> Although I thought Zeus was going to be in the
house.
Oh, [__]
>> Guys, let's stop chucking water on each other now. Sit
down and finish the voting, please.
>> You're not even a streamer. The only reason you're here
is because you're [__] going pumping [__]
Nobody knows you. Nobody cares about you. I can't believe they
even have you here. Nobody's on your [__] damn
it. It's here. Nobody.
>> That's Eli, who actually has AIDS, by the way. Uh, this
guy.
That's rough. >> What the [__] you're saying?
>> You're so hard. You're so
nice. Yeah. Yeah. You like that? You like that? You like one
more? Yeah. Do you want one? Yeah. Do it again.
>> Uh,
why does everybody spit? Why can't you guys just be normal?
Why is this people's go-to? It's so disgusting.
>> Like, actually, just hit each other. Don't spit in somebody's
face.
>> Come to the dining room, spitting on
>> Stop spitting on her.
>> Come to the dining room. Stop spitting on my [__]
>> Throw my Yeah, throwing my phone. Throwing personal
property. Haven't thrown anyone's phone. >> Throwing [__]
in my face. Haven't spit in anyone's face. >> MK just always
escalates and then is shocked that people like are bad at her.
>> It's [__] ridiculous. Like every time. All
right, I'm going to What are we going to now?
Going to is day two. Day three. I think this might be day three
stuff. Yeah, I was moving into day three. Okay, >> Got
some time stamps for day three.
Looking through them all. Some less highlights right here. >> Okay,
it does not work like that. You get down and you get your [__]
[__] >> The toilet will not flush. >> I'm
sorry. >> I just took a thumb. I hope he's not going down.
Normal size thumb. This is like a blue.
>> I'm serious. >> Normal [__] >> Didn't
blast with toilet paper. It's a normal mountain there. not flushing
and like drain the water and it's not flushing. You're going
to go show
>> how there's no wonder.
>> No, it's not like
Okay, Kell, please stop. Zeus. Isn't Zeus like in shape? You're
saying Wes looks like Zeus? Isn't that insane?
Wes is a very large man and not in the same way that Zeus is.
Okay.
Slices. Slice you with what? No. No. I'm telling you it's not
a seism thing. The water went up and down. Fine. >> It's
the worst. >> It's like
he let us know that
doesn't matter. It's not like it's over engorged. It's like the
suction. It's a >> If you want to investigate [__]
you go through something.
There's not a track.
>> There's not. >> What? You serious? >> Don't
talk to me.
Monster [__]
>> I I I can't think of something else to say there. Wes
just said it all. Okay. Toilet's clogged. GG. Toilet's clogged.
GG. It's over.
>> Hey, I'm down.
He sent a
That's right.
do you know how to say uh the day after tomorrow?
Oh yeah.
>> My favorite one is going to be Fama
or like
>> All right. All right. We're done. We're done with Wes
clogging the toilets.
Mike Smalls is coming up next. Mike Smalls getting in a fight
with Sam, moving some furniture around.
>> The audio sucks. It does suck. What can we do? >> What
can we do, guys?
>> What are you doing?
>> That's easier.
>> yeah, that seems like not a great idea.
>> He's trying to push himself. He's literally pushing
himself over.
>> literally trying to do this to
>> Oh god, that's going to break. Oh,
>> you going to
>> This is uh Okay,
>> it's fixable.
>> It's fixable.
in the house. $450 deduction.
>> It's fixable. Look. And I can fix it though. I did what?
>> Nice on the floor. >> I think you got to get something.
>> Mike's on the floor, baby.
he had a Z the whole time. >> Mike was he just
>> I I have a hard time. So Mike gets in a fight with Sam
here. Like he's he's yelling at Sam. Sam's yelling at him. I
have a hard time taking any of this seriously because that was
just so manufactured for no reason. That was just stupid. That's
like even more manufactured than most of this content would be.
Okay. >> What? What happened? >> What a [__]
[__]
>> He's uh going to get into a West M >> He's he's
terrified of me. >> He's literally literally terrified.
He's so fearful.
>> You're in a room nowhere nowhere near me. I can't be
the out of you. You have no physical threat. Why are you so scared
to even speak to me?
>> Speak to me. Where the [__] are you?
>> Yeah, like [__] the show. Remember,
speak to me. I let you in. I let you in, >> It's actually
>> Speak to me.
Talk to no one ever again. I wish your voice box didn't work.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Let me laugh like a [__] >> W
is right. You're a complete [__] world. [__]
yourself. You're a clown. We don't care about that lame ass show.
Here we go. >> Wes looks like a bag of mashed potatoes
with legs. >> [__] up. That's [__]
up. Wes,
>> do you think Wes is allowed to get on Discord while
he's here? I don't know if that would be allowed.
>> I wonder big brother. You stay one week. >> What
the Wait, is Cubebot going live on kick now?
>> Just straight up switch over to kick. >> Jesus
will save you. >> She not even doing Twitch anymore.
West bitching because I need to make sure you have no chance
cuz you ruined this [__] narrative. This is a house.
You are nothing. You ruin it. You deserve to get kicked out.
It is a house built on games. You are not playing the game. That's
not how a house works.
>> That's not how it works. Have you? Every
>> every deduction is because you don't play the [__]
game. Go next. Go next. Go anywhere else. Don't be here. Let
people play this [__] game. >> The second you
leave, I'll leave. >> No, you said you don't leave. >> The
second you leave, I'll leave. You walk out, I'll leave. You leave,
I leave. You leave, I leave. You leave, I leave. Do you want
You want me to go walk out? Walk the [__] out. You
obviously care cuz I'm in your mind. I'm an insect controlling
your thoughts. I'm parasitic. I'm sucking your life force out.
You're going to be withered into a [__] husk soon.
You have nothing. I dominate every [__]
>> Wes is Merk's AIDS. Okay. Every little [__]
tell in your body is controlled by me. I'm in your brain pulling
the two little strings, making you walk, making you talk, making
you crash out, getting a couple kW's out of it. But you're under
my control, you freak peasant. You're under my control.
>> You're under mine. >> Okay, I'm not going to lie.
I kind of have to go see if I can find Wes's rant from a first
party perspective. Okay.
From first person point of view. Can I get his rant here? >> Where's
his like rant at Merc? Give me a
>> Yeah. Yeah. This is it. This is it. This is it. I got
it. I got it. I got it. >> A house built on games. You
are not playing the game. That's not how a house
>> That's not how it works. Have you? Every
>> Every deduction is because you don't play the game.
Go next. Go next. Go anywhere else. Don't be here. Let people
play the game. >> The second you leave, I'll leave. >> No.
You said you >> The second you leave, I'll leave. You walk
out, I leave. You leave, I leave. You leave, I leave. You leave,
I leave. You leave, I leave. You leave, I leave. Walk out. Walk
the [__] out. You obviously care cuz I'm in your
mind. I'm an insect controlling your thoughts. I'm parasitic.
I'm sucking your life force out. You're going to be withered
into a [__] husk soon. You have nothing. I dominate
every physical being. Every little cell in your body is controlled
by me. I'm in your brain pulling the two little strings, making
you walk, making you talk, making you crash out, getting a couple
k W's out of it. But you're under my control, you freak peasant.
You're under my control. >> Yeah, you seem very >> You're
under mine. >> You're under mine. >> You seem very
>> Okay, hold on. Hold on. Let me see if I got Wes's whole
crash out here or not. I thought I did. Maybe I don't. Uh,
this seems to be somewhere around where it happens.
We're homies, right? >> Yeah, real. You're >> right,
Play-Doh man. Goodbye, bro. Why do you admit you have HIV?
>> So, you
have HIV.
>> I guess not. Maybe not. Maybe not. >> I fix my
knee. Will >> someone need to No bed sheet. >> I
thought this was it, but I don't think so. I don't know why we
can't find uh merch [__] >> You want to go
to party? You You want You want to go party, huh? Party here.
party here. But you say they want to go
>> Who are all the participants in this big brother ripoff?
I know Wes. I guess there's Nelly. I don't know who that is.
Uh Wes Murk, Mike Smalls Jr. I don't know the other guy.
And then there's Moxy. Nelly Murk. I'm not sure if there's another.
>> Oh, and whoever that Russian girl is. >> No, I
don't. You ask me. >> I don't want to go anymore.
You the other guy. Okay. >> Because it's same wife, right?
Why? Because self streaming right now. You You don't want to.
>> I know what you're talking about. >> What is this?
This is the next time stamp we got here. Merc massage. I don't
know what this is. Oh, what the hell
is being naughty?
>> Did the age turn out to be real? I don't believe so.
>> Am I naughty? I don't
>> Are you naughty? I don't know. Nothing.
>> No. You tell me. I don't know. >> I don't I haven't
seen any naughty side of you yet. You know, >> you see
kind of innocent.
>> Just uh very weird.
>> Dude said, "Let me sit in a [__] [__]
chair in a corner." >> This is uh Sam Pande apparently.
>> 64
6:00, dude. >> Guys, let me film it. I'm good. >> It's
actually 6:00 and we're having good
>> This is a thought. >> Look, we don't care that
you slobbered on your pillow. >> No, like my face was >> Dude,
this is uh this is just weird for the time stamp for this. I
actually got to it a little too early. I didn't even click on
the time stamp was just
slash cameraman turns up turns up. Guy walks in. He's like, I'll
film it. Let me film it.
>> I'm so ready for this. >> My bad. Are you fine?
>> Oh, here. I'll show you. >> No, it's okay. >> You're
fine. >> Oh, is this the Was this the Merc time >> Where
the [__] are you POV?
>> Okay, I'll watch I'll watch this one more time to the
show. Remember, grab a >> Speak to me. >> I let you
in. I let you in, Sam.
>> You
This is a complete [__] up with content. [__]
yourself. You're a clown. We don't care about that lame ass show.
Here we go. Make sure you have no chance cuz you ruined this
[__] narrative. This is a house. You are nothing.
You ruin it. You deserve to get kicked out. It is a house built
on game. You are not playing the game. This is just in the rule
of thirds. Okay. In terms of camera shots, Wes is Wes's gut is
like perfectly placed to be one of the one of the focuses of
this shot. Okay. >> That's not how a house works. >> It's
insane camera work for Mark. >> Have you every deduction?
>> Yeah. Every deduction is because you don't play the
[__] Is that you leave, I leave. You walk out, I'll
leave. You leave, I leave. You leave, I leave. You leave, I leave.
Do you want You want me to go? Walk out. Walk the [__]
out. You obviously care cuz I'm in your mind. I'm an insect controlling
your thoughts. I'm parasitic. I'm sucking your life force out.
You're going to be withered into a husk soon. You have nothing.
I dominate every physical being. Every little cell in your body
is controlled by me. I'm in your brain, pulling the two little
strings, making you walk, making you talk, making you crash out,
getting a couple KWs out of it. But you're under my control,
you freak peasants. You're under my control.
>> Yeah, you can. >> You're under mine. >> you're
under mine.
>> you seem very right now. >> Do you want to go
partying? You saved me today. Like, uh, you want you want,
>> huh? Right. Why? >> Because I'm streaming right
now. You you you don't want
>> I was bored. Now I'm not
>> [__] How can you [__] >> Yeah,
that's she said like a secret
>> Yeah, let's go. Let's go outside for gifts or like pins
and like secret like
>> You're trying to work your way back in. I won't let
you. >> I'm the [__] game. I'm made out of
steel, [__] Yeah, most you're like a 9 mil. You ain't
getting through this this whole bulletproof and I ain't opening
the [__] gate. You play the game right or you'll
never make a single friend in this house. You will be the pariah,
the outcast. People will hate you. You'll be the [__]
thunderclap war
I'm spy. Yeah.
>> Is he uh is Wes a torren warrior like a tank? Thunderclap
war stomp.
Okay.
Never been spy.
Never. No. No milk. No. More. More. I was in here. >> Don't
care. Get mad. Don't speak. You aren't allowed to speak. >> Here's
a request. Stop. >> Uh, okay. Not a goofball. Uh,
time stamp for this. This seems insane, but
10 million denied 15 today. No, 45. 45, I think it was. >> Good
night.
>> Sims doesn't care about the rules. Rules don't matter
in this house. They're a fabrication.
just so this money can go down. But you notice that every day
everyone else got deducted huge amounts, but the one person who's
committed the most infractions, zero deductions. He wants these
ballers all to be very full. So there's maximum deduction, but
he doesn't want anyone to get kicked out. He doesn't want the
game to work. He wants the game to work for his benefit. We exist
purely as an operating table to profit for this gang. >> Marty
for 17 months. >> He's disgusting. >> Do not throw
me. Do not throw at me. Do not throw [__] at me.
Do not throw [__] at me. >> Oh [__]
she caught it.
>> Do not
terrible aim. >> Personal property. You're gone. >> I
don't even I can do whatever the [__] I want. >> You're
throwing [__] >> You're throwing [__]
>> Throwing things.
Stop throwing things like
>> Why are you not talking to Sandy? Why are you hiding
like a boy? Why are you hiding like a little boy?
>> you're just scared. >> No, you can do this. Why
are you so You didn't deserve this [__] for mine.
You deducted tons from everyone else. You're maximizing the maximize
your profit, but you want no one to leave at at day 30. You want
everyone's deduction to be
We I know you're paying, Sam. I'm smarter than you. You're just
threw a non baby. Is that a deduction?
>> Oh, guess what? Another non-deduction. Another non-deduction.
>> My feelings would
Oh, no. >> You're terrible at life. Another
>> I still need minus money. Money. They finally cling.
>> She should be paying down. She should be forced out
of the house. >> She said, "Stop." >> Dude, Wes is
like the only person doing any content.
>> She knows you want the ducks. >> Crazy is what's
more important is you want me to get out of the house instead
of you're dwindling down the prize >> I'm not dwindling.
You can do the chop. I'm asking you nothing. I'm asking you the
smallest thing. Peel a banana. Kill a banana. Pill a banana.
Say hello. Stop
>> You're directly us. You're directly [__]
us. You're directly [__] us. I'm asking you small
requests. Nothing. You're [__] us. You're [__]
us. You're [__] us. You're [__] us. You're
[__] us.
>> You're the only thing.
>> Hold on. Different West Crash out on
You're not talking. You're not talking. You're not talking. I'm
talking. You're not talking. I'm talking. You're not talking.
If you don't want to play the game, get rid of the [__]
game or kick out talking. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
That might be the same day. Hold on. Are these are the same outfits?
Is this literally the same day? Does he get a hat at some point?
Is this just going to go forever? I'm looking. I don't see if
he just gets a hat here. This appears to be on the same day.
>> These challenges, you have denied every single one.
>> What' you say? >> You are. >> If I asked
Mike to do anything as of you, he all of it. No money would be
taken out. >> I hear you. You're a miserable [__]
running for me.
>> All right. >> I can't hear you. >> Wait,
the the six is still the normal thing, Mike or not? Or
Sam, what are you
>> Are we going back to the control? >> You can um
you can smoke in the smoking area now. And um we'll drop off
the Tai cigarettes soon. >> That's cool. >> We're
not going to talk about at all. You You answer about that, but
nothing else. We just >> Oh my god. kind of fat [__]
No one respects you. Oh my god. Respect you >> Oh my god.
Get out of the house, fat >> Hey, still throwing things
at me. Don't worry about me. He's still throwing things at me.
Don't worry about a [__] >> I'm not throwing
anything. I follow the rules cuz I'm playing the game. When he
said this response, I'm having a stroke right now. Be so sick.
>> Well, you're closer to a stroke than me, >> Be
so sick. >> You're closer to a stroke than me. >> Have
a stroke. That'd be >> You're closer to his stroke than
me, >> So, the master server request thing doesn't matter
all. Exactly. No. Exactly. No, cuz you're fat. >> No, cuz
you're fat. You're fat.
>> We're making special rules for this. This is what we're
making special. You want to throw water at me? >> Oh, no.
I'll give you some water, though. You want some water? >> No,
I'm okay. >> You want some water? >> No, I'm okay.
>> You want some water? >> Oh, you can throw it.
>> Wait, what?
>> There's no way. After the 15 requests and the assault
earlier, he's only deducted 50 bucks for deduct for throwing
Sam. >> Okay. Is he really going to call that assault?
Come on, Wes. >> You're a [__] rat. Ry,
>> I don't know if Wes does Wes abuse women. I guess he
kind of does like verbally.
I feel like I wouldn't expect him to be physically abusive, but
he does. He definitely He definitely does. She slapped his hand
earlier. Oh, well.
Oh, let me look at I might watch the short again. >> You're
not talking. I'm talking. You're not talking. You're not talking.
You're not talking. I'm talking. You're not talking. I'm talking.
You're not talking. If you don't want to play the game, get rid
of the [__] game or kick out the psycho of cheating.
Or if you touch me, I'll take you so hard in your [__]
face, [__] Don't you [__] touch me. >> I'll
beat a woman's ass. Don't [__] touch me. >> Come
on, Wes. W I just defended you, Wes. You stupid.
Do not threaten to fight women the second I say, "Don't think
you'd hit a woman, you stupid."
>> I will rock your [__]
>> You touched me. >> No, I did. >> Yes, you
did.
>> Did you hit that guy?
>> You touched me. You had no idea. >> Yes, you did.
Good. >> Jesus Christ.
>> Break the rules, get consequences. You touch me with
this, I'm sorry. >> Don't touch people.
Stop it, M.
>> [__] idiot, bro. >> In my room.
>> Okay, Murk's got to find a different thing than just
dumping drinks on people. Okay, this is kind of wild. It's like
her thing in every clip. Like, how are you making dumping drinks
on people boring? What's going on here?
>> Oh my god, bro.
>> Dumping drinks on a bed.
>> Oh, this is vinegar or something. I don't even know.
>> I need to separate them.
>> I have no idea. >> This is just going to be like
she's going to be gone eventually.
>> Your [__] mother. Your mother.
your community doesn't do you
[__] I don't want to use my [__] [__]
You want to use my [__] [__] >> Like,
it's crazy.
>> Like, at this point,
at this point,
Sam needs to pull whatever strings he's got. He's got to do a
jailbreak. Okay. There's a little jail in Texas that is holding
the key to this content being saved, Sam. And you can make it
happen. Okay. 10 grand, 20 grand, 30 grand. You can make that
jailbreak happen. You can bring the content, Sam. There's only
one person who can tame MC, who can make sure she's not everything
up. All right. Break glass in case of needing content. I've heard
Darius has just flown out to Thailand.
I think we all know
what we need here, right? We all can see. We all know. Wait,
Zena is still in jail. I believe she may still be in jail. It
I think she had a hearing today. I did not hear the result of
that hearing. I believe she was still in jail as of today. Zena,
I believe Zena was still in jail as of today, if I'm not mistaken.
>> Return to your bedroom. I'm going to evict you if you
don't return to your
>> What the [__] is
[__] pay for getting [__] like this?
If I [__] put one on this [__] camera,
isn't it going to be okay? Sam, where the [__] did
you invite me to? Is this [__] okay? pay for this
[__] Do you pay for this [__] >> You're
not talking. You're not talking. I'm talking. You're not talking.
You're not talking. You're not talking. I'm talking. You're not
talking. I'm talking. You're not talking. If you don't want to
play the game, get rid of the [__] game or kick out
the psycho of cheating. Or if you touch me, I'll take you so
hard on your [__] face, [__] Don't you
[__] touch me. >> I'll be a woman's ass. >> Don't
[__] touch me. I'm not touching >> I will rock
your [__] Personality.
>> Did you hit that guy? Christ. Whoops. You need plant
dad. He's the lore master. Yeah. He said to watch clips. I said,
"Hey, link something." And he wasn't around. He's doing stuff.
He's busy.
He's busy. Okay.
This is awful content. This is not awful content. This is This
is perfectly good content. I don't know why you'd say it's awful
content when tons of people love Fish Tank, tons of people love
Big Brother, tons of people are going to like this. That's just
a That's a terrible eye for content. Peanobub Wes and Lupluca
have a spirited talk about national representation.
[__] is this?
>> I'm Russ.
>> You ever seen an American?
>> I'm going to [__] I'm going to go. Please
keep yelling at me. Homework
>> yeah. That's crazy. Good luck. You're >> [__]
luck with this [__] dude. I'm not doing this for
you. This is cancer. It's so hard. >> Oh, I've seen some
clips of this. Hold
>> Better. I'm better off.
>> Yo, guys. This is >> This This next one is rough.
I think Have I seen this one? I think I've seen this one. This
is titled Murk Thinks the Knife Isn't that hot,
>> bro? It's not working.
>> Yeah, we need an actual >> Is it really? Is it
hot, though? >> Yeah, it's it's hot. It's hot. It's hot.
Trust me, it's hot. No, it's hot.
>> I didn't think it was like that hot. >> It's a
hot.
You crazy.
>> That hurt. >> Okay, that's not quite as funny
as I thought it would be. It's another link. Another look at
the West crash out here.
>> Come on, camera guy. >> You're not talking. I'm
talking. >> Well, I do want to see him slap the phone out
of her head from this angle. >> Anyway, I >> Exactly.
It's all [__]
>> Or kick her out. If you don't want to play the game,
get rid of the [__] game or kick out the psychoso
cheating. You touch me. I'll bet you sword your [__]
face, [__] Don't you [__] touch me. >> I'll
beat a woman's ass. >> Don't [__] touching
you. >> I will rock your [__] >> I'm
not touching you. >> All I'm saying, play the [__]
rules. >> I'm not touching you. >> Play the [__]
game. touching you. >> Stick to the game or kill the game.
>> Let the house go. >> Okay, she's explicitly reaching
out to try to touch it. >> Don't [__] play
that game. >> I'm not touching you. >> Let the [__]
game be real. >> I'm not touching you. >> Let the
game be real.
>> Yeah. See, see her lean it back to try to use one of
the legs to touch him.
>> She's poking him in the stomach now.
>> That was one poke.
>> Going for another poke.
She's poking the bear.
What's going to happen?
>> You touch me. >> No, I did. >> Yes, you
did. Clip it. >> Don't [__] me.
>> Don't [__] me.
>> Watch
me. >> Would you just go to go to the
You can take your phone in the tripod when I deal with this.
Thank you. >> What did he say in the lower room? >> Don't
[__] touch me. I didn't
click. Check the clip. Restart.
>> Check the camera.
>> I took our phone out of her [__] >> Check
the dams POV. Okay, hold on. Let's pull it up. Let's pull it
up. Let's pull it up. Let's pull it up. Where is it at? Here
it is. >> We haven't even
>> You touched me. >> No, I didn't. >> Yes,
you did. Clip it. >> Don't [__] me. Haven't
even here yet. I was going to be doing
>> you touched me. >> No, I didn't. >> Yes,
she did. >> Uh, yeah, she did. >> Funny development
is the Indian guy apparently has a assault charge or allegation
and the Indian guy and MC have been cuddling the past two nights.
He's been sing for her and she's trying to make Darius jealous.
She might the Indian guy for revenge before Darius gets there.
That seems >> Wait, M, would you just be able to go to
the lower bedroom for a second? You can take your phone and the
tripod when I deal with this. Thank you. >> You can take
your phone in the tripod when I deal with this. Thank you. >> Where
did he say the lower room?
>> Yeah, the lower bedroom. Thank you. >> Don't [__]
touch me. I told you lower >> Check the clip. Check the
camera.
>> It wasn't I took your phone out of this
>> Don't [__] touch me. Break the rules. Get
consequences.
You touch me with it, I disarm you. Suck my dick.
>> Okay. Uh, I think that's it for time stamps so far,
guys.
>> I think that's it. I don't know what else we got going
on with this, but that seems to be
all we've done so far for time stamps. >> I might have
a couple more. Let me check
the whole time. >> Disarm. What violence? No [__]
violence. Watch your clip. Watch your
No [__] violence. I didn't hit her. >> Wait,
really? That's not the same Russian girl.
Lup is the girl that was like Zena was like slapping her to get
her out of like uh self harm or whatever. And then Moxy
is the girl who's filming herself.
>> Bro, it [__] stroked past her stomach. Nah,
bro. That's [__] crazy.
Nah, bro. Wait till you see this, bro. You guys are going to
be like, >> you guys are going to be like, "What the when
you see this
cry baby walk around the rest of the
>> Wait, what is this?
>> I don't think it's the same girl, but yeah, it was Maria
Fort. Yeah, I didn't think it was the same girl. >> You're
so hard. You're so hard.
Oh, nice. Yeah. Yeah. You like that? You like that? Yeah. You
like >> But the Asian girl here, the Moxy girl, that's
uh that's the girl. No, she's not Asian. The Moxy girl might
be the girl who's uh like mogging into the camera. Well, Zena
did crazy.
>> Yeah. Do you want one? Yeah. Do it
>> We watched this already. Gross. Spitting is gross. Stop
spitting on each other. It's weird.
It's weird. Yeah, you did a little Euroracism tape deck. It's
a little little weird. Little messed up. Not cool. Not cool.
Okay. All right. Moxy got kicked from the house, I think. I don't
know why she isn't there anymore. Well, someone said she was
getting replaced. Do West forget all of his Wes explicitly threw
out all of his shirts. So, he would be shirtless for this entire
thing. Okay.
Wes made that decision. Honestly, he he came by that decision
honestly. Let's look at the clips from Sam's stream for the past
day. See if we got anything cool.
Wes smacks MC. MC goes nuts. Oh, let's check this out. Picture
of MK as a giraffe.
>> Take the girl. Take the girl back outside the other
side of the car.
>> Quickly, Peggy. Quickly run.
>> It's not mine. What are you doing?
>> Get this
blue hoodie. Take her to the other side of this curtain and keep
her
>> Inside the kitchen. In the kitchen.
>> Take her to the other side of the curtain. Just tell
him to go take her.
>> Was I going to >> take her?
I didn't see her go for the bottle. Hold
>> She did. She did. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Wes was not around there. She went to pick up a glass
bottle. Wes was like, "No, no, no. We're not doing this."
>> Disarming,
dude.
>> Why would you take the glass?
>> Oh, I'm done. I'm getting
>> Yeah, that little Southeast Asian guy. That security
guys.
>> Who is this?
>> Merk's not gone. She's not a [__] evicted.
I need to separate the two. I can't have them [__]
fighting right
>> I was not
going to take my >> She pours a beer out of the tobacco.
I knew she going to do some dumb [__] like
>> She wants to [__] up as much as she
She was [__] assho
about other people
with this crazy we did target my dick.
Why did she target my dick with a water >> Did you think
I was hard to get soft?
>> Why wasn't my target with water?
>> Dam's employees. Okay. Yes.
Yeah, it is a little bit like that. I didn't I clicked the link
before I was ready.
>> It do be like that a little bit.
>> What do you get when you down sweet?
>> It'd be like that a little bit. Okay. Be like that just
a little bit. It's the hot knife clip. >> Very strange
target. Yeah. Why did you purposely hit me in the like my dick?
What do you mean? Oh, we lost the blackjack part. Wait, is this
yours? >> No, I mean I got mine. It's >> yours.
Come back.
>> Come back. Let's be honest. >> You want to be
here, brother? >> Give her one more night's painting. Get
>> More challenges, less murder. More challenges, less
murder. More challenges, less murder.
>> That might be the most tenant situation we've had so
far. Dude, I just want to go. I'm literally trying to like
>> said security is his girlfriend's uncle. I can see that.
>> He's yelling at his girlfriend right now. Like this
whole time. He's like him and his girlfriend have clearly been
in a fight like this entire time.
>> Coming with a three lb beer bottle, bro.
>> He's coming back. >> Yeah, dude. Dad's coming
back. Dude, this is a deadly weapon. >> [__]
yes it is. >> There is no beer in any of people, bro. [__]
yeah, it is. Hey, it's not like serious. I'm not taking a [__]
hit of the puppy. That wouldn't feel good. That wouldn't be
>> YouTube clip of him crashing out on her. Apparently,
it's coming up. So, I'm not I'm not pausing cuz they're literally
fighting. You can see them fighting like with his transparent
background. You can't see her, but you can see him looking over
to like scream into the corner constantly.
>> No, she shouldn't be cute. No, no. Let her back. No,
no, no, no. Don't they
>> She should get for not playing the [__]
game.
She didn't [__] me at me. You could argue that she
tried. >> But no, no, no.
>> Deductions. Sure. For the beer and the salt and the
water, whatever. Let her rack that on. It's probably way over
5K the clips coming in. But don't cure your >> Don't think
you
>> No, no, no. I don't think you >> Oh, West himself.
>> What is the sound in his background?
She threw water in my dick. Okay, can we stop body shaming Wes
right now? This is kind of fun.
>> It's kind of worse. >> That same morning, Wes
was on the phone with Peggy. You could hear Sam screaming in
the background.
>> We can play fearful.
>> You got Mr.
>> That's my beer. Let's be
>> I don't know, boys. I'm going to be straight up when
it comes to beer. I'm a beer and I think water cup is gay as
[__] What do you think? I'm a beer and cup beer bonger.
>> What? beer and cup. >> Like you play with the
with beer in the cup and then when the cup's made and it's removed,
you drink.
>> Water. So [__]
>> Yeah. Hold on. Let me see if I can find Sam, Pepper,
Peggy.
See if we can find them fighting just recently. Come on. Come
on.
This week. Nope. Nope. I took the clip of that, but I can't I
can't see it. >> Beer in a cup.
>> Yes. We guys are not gay. We You don't drink any of
that go to waste. So yeah, it's every cup drink. >> [__]
yeah. The losing the losing team. >> You have
you have a dirty bean combo going in the >> No, no, no.
You have a water cup between the beer ball
before every shot
or anything. You have you. So I have 10 cups. 10 cups. We each
have a water cup and then we play two one v one. The winner or
the winner also wins. The loser drinks whatever cups remain.
>> She have problem. She have fun with him today. But she
she didn't about other people. She chewed all tobacco.
Don't touch my tobacco. That was so >> Don't touch my tobacco.
Don't touch my tobacco. Have you never touch my
>> Phone call. Oh, this is the West phone call. Hold on.
Give me a second. >> Okay, after this I'm going to probably
I'm going to fire up that Adam Freeland interview shortly. I
do want to check that out. And I'm going to do it on
Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello.
Tell him to go away. >> Tell the guy to go away.
>> Sam is screaming at max volume. Peggy's trying to dug
me and Sam is screaming, "Get the [__] off the phone,
bro. Get the [__] off the phone."
>> Why is Wes farming that? That's That's kind of up, dude.
>> Wait, you're joking, right? >> You're [__]
joking, right?
>> No, just call him. Does he not speak Thai? Do you not
speak Thai to that? both not speak Thai. >> I told him
to wait there. >> How hard is it to communicate that? I
just My mind is blown. I just don't know how that's hard to communicate.
>> Wait, you're joking, right?
>> Wait, what? >> The song I eat it more.
>> Put it in a clear bowl so I can see it. >> Okay,
fine. No, Rowan. It was a waffle actually. It was a waffle. >> Man,
you are. >> It was a waffle.
>> It was a waffle. >> He's gay, by the way. >> I
am not gay. And you don't have any proof to say >> you
are. >> What is that rea? I am not gay. And you have no
proof that I am gay. Okay. You cannot prove any. No. >> Because
you asked for everything. You paid for me. You said because I
love you. I pay for you. Now what? You asked me back everything.
You b gay. >> I am not a gay. >> Your attitude as
well like you taking girl hormone.
>> Are you happy now? >> You're taking bear hormone.
>> Hormone attitude is where I would like
to your attitude as well. Like you taking bear hormone.
>> Are you happy now? We're finished. Thank you for your
>> birth hormone. I thought calling him a gay was funny.
I did not see them fight in Japan. did not see any of that.
>> Like I don't know. I told him too, you know. I told
>> Why are you shouting at me? Of course I'm going to be
upset by it because I hired him and I paid for him and he's not
doing his job. I'm okay. That's fine for me to be upset. >> I
told >> it's fine for me to be upset, but it's not fine
for you to be upset at me being upset that he's not doing his
job. >> You're yelling at me and you're saying that this
is going to do that. >> Yes, you did. You said that more
premium. I'm going to have to pay more.
>> I know. So, you recommended them to me. Oh my god.
>> God, you're ruining my show.
>> Gummy, stay for the 3 months. Let's go. >> You're
ruining my show. >> Why don't you blame me >> right
now? No, I'm saying right now. You
>> Because I've got to do this, not do you.
Please blaming me.
Why? >> No, I'm saying be quiet. You're ruining my actively.
>> This is the content. >> Now you are. >> Darius
apparently just landed in Thailand. Jacob. Darius is on his way.
Darius is on his way for the contest.
>> You want to show me or do you want to show you? >> Now
you are.
right now. You are
>> Tell Panda to talk to the security
>> I swear I saw security plots on three
>> Dude, seriously. The fight starts back here. Apparently
>> you I deducted Murk uh 300 for pouring three bottles
of uh alcohol which leaves her at Let me look. I mean this is
just going to be a joke. I mean I don't I honestly don't really
know where it's going to go from here. I spoke to I spoke to
Merc in detail about it and then that fun time. I'm already angry
on
>> I think they were fighting. This is the pausing and
yelling was back here. We were watching right here's here's W
West with his hands on his hips talking about getting Murk kicked
out or whatever. Yeah. And we we were watching them pause fight
pause like he was muting. He was yelling into the corner and
then it's about 10 minutes and then >> let the gauntlet
begin. Release the hounds. I don't know. Let's get this TTS done
and then I'll tell them they can leave. Let's just get a TTS
done first. >> Okay. Well, that security guy is
>> I mean, that's why I shouting at >> Sammy. I promise.
>> Not at her. I was saying tell him to stop. Tell him
to stop. >> Security trained by the Navy. >> You
because you're the one on the phone to him, Peggy. >> Uh,
Mercy is a huge liability with huge mental disorders. Told you.
>> Oh my god. All right. You want to have this? You want
to have this on stream? Sit here because I was muted and they
can see me angry last time, but they can't hear what you're saying.
Let's tell them about the security right from the [__]
beginning. You want to have it on stream? You want to have the
argument on stream? Let's have it.
>> Okay. The security went in the room. They gave the phone
to Wes. Wes used the phone. The security uh put things in when
they're not meant to. The security
>> I fired one of them. Yeah. I'm already fired because
I speak >> I'm already angry. Right. I'm already >> You
shout at me. You shout >> and I I told them. >> You
shout at me. I told them I vote for you though. >> No,
I was shouting. Tell him to stop. Tell him to stop it. Tell him
to step in between. No, this one just now. >> Yeah, I told
him though. >> I wasn't shouting. You are saying, "Stop
it. Stop it." I was showing you the urgency of the situation.
>> Him before you even >> But you screamed at You
screamed at me for no reason. You I'm screaming at you because
there's a reason. I'm not screaming at you. I'm screaming at
you to say, "Do this quickly." I'm showing you the urgency of
it. I'm not saying I'm not saying Oh, Peggy's a [__]
>> You good, Kger? Yeah, she's literally walked on camera,
but are you good? Why does that matter? >> [__]
[__] I'm saying Peggy, tell him to do something.
Tell him to stop it. He's standing there like a lost puppy. Tell
him to do something. That's why I'm screaming. >> You screaming
at me, >> mad person. I am saying that. >> Yes, I'm
cautious. Cuz people have beer balls and they've just been fighting
and we hire security and I need them to do something and they're
doing nothing. If I could speak Thai, I wouldn't be screaming
at you. I'd be on the phone to the security guard and I'd be
like, "Stop them. Stop them. What are you doing? Why are you
just standing there? Stop them. Stop them. But I can't. So I
>> This makes it so much funnier that the security guard
just hands the phone to Wes and Wes is like talking to Peggy
while Sam just screams in the >> Have to shout at you so
you understand the energy that you need to have. >> You
know, maybe
>> maybe in his entire work never met this kind of in his
life. So he doesn't know how to act, you know, just have some
empathy like I told him. I told him he's >> Did I not tell
you? >> You know why I hire this company? You know why
I hide this company and it's helping you.
>> It's cover your head.
>> Yelling at me. I didn't pee. I feed you. I running around
>> and then I come back. I didn't eat at all. And I I didn't
pee. I come back serve you food and I go pee and yell at me when
I'm peeing. Oh, pee quickly. Pee quickly. I have a few seconds.
Well, [__] you.
[__] you. Keep that >> I've had this for 4
days, by the way,
>> Because I [__] help you and you're dreaming
like [__] Do I [__] suck that [__]
>> Peggy? I I was screaming. Tell him that >> I was
screaming at you to tell him to
>> Wait, quickly. I ran here. I ran here half naked trying
to pull my pants up to talk to you.
>> Okay. But for real though,
why doesn't Peggy ever wear pants? I swear to God, I've seen
her like three times on stream. I've watched like 2 hours of
Sam's content total. And every time she's trying to pull pants
on, I'm not even joking. I'm not joking. every single time she's
trying to pull pants >> because what you >> cuz I
had it it was a serious situation I needed to do. I >> I
weren't saying like get here you stupid [__] I'm
saying hey Peggy, can you come here quickly? >> I've got
to deal with this. I've got to deal with this. >> Have
some empathy for you. >> Yeah, I know. I beg you. >> I
know it's stressful. I understand it's >> Putting up with
you. >> I know it's stressful.
Yeah, I'm stressed too. >> What is this? This is better
contextually relevant. If this is just a clip, I'm not going
to be happy. I'm just I'm just telling you now. This seems like
it's just going to be a clip and I don't do it. This is absolutely
just going to be a clip. This is absolutely just going to be
a clip.
>> This is person. Why did you link me this? What did you
link me this for? >> I'm stressed every day. Do you not
see me on stream stressed every day? >> You're here, too.
Hey, I didn't [__] >> I mean, you what?
>> You've eaten. You have You're right next to the Do you
not see me on stream stressed every day? >> I didn't You're
here, too. >> I didn't [__] pee. >> I
didn't eat. I didn't pee. You're in an apartment. You're not
even in the same
You're not
>> I mean, you could have eaten. You You're right next
to the restaurant. You could have just got food. >> It's
closed. >> Okay. Well, order food then. I I mean I told
you I'm going to order food. I'm hungry. And you said, "Yeah,
you should order food. Eat." I I mean, you're you're 23 years
old. You did have time, Peggy. You had to bring three crates
of alcohol. That was it. You had It's It's now It's now 10:00.
We woke up at 10:30 and you had to bring three crates of alcohol.
Don't act like you've been running around doing crazy things
all >> I did though. >> You went to the super. >> Dude,
every single camera in this house Oh, never mind. Never mind.
I'm zoomed in. I was about to say it cuz I thought I thought
this was just the shot. I forgot I was zoomed in. I was like,
"Bro, why is every single camera in this house tuned to Wes's
gut?" They just find Wes's gut naturally. He just becomes the
focus in the room every >> You got three crates of alcohol
and three chickens. You had time to eat. You had time to do things.
Peggy, >> Peggy, it's 10:00 at night. >> Come on.
Come on. >> I didn't eat though. >> Come on. >> I
didn't eat though. >> Come on. >> How come empathy
for me? >> I do. I understand you're hungry. Yeah. I feel
sorry you're hungry. I didn't shout at you like you're a piece
of I was shouting you. You >> shouting at me like that.
>> No, I was shouting. He needs to do something. He's standing
there like >> Where your >> Why is this just bouncing
in the >> I'm on me. Please. >> This is actually
kind of keen content. >> It looks good on me. Huh? It looks
funny. Just bouncing on me. You would be calm in my situation.
No, you wouldn't. You'd be screaming. Get him to do something
quickly. Get him to do something quickly. Get him to do something
quickly. It looks terrible on me. So I'm screaming get him to
do something. I'm not screaming you. You
>> I'm not I'm screaming. >> Don't scream at me.
And you said some >> because it's an emergency.
>> Cuz it's an emergency.
How do you not
>> No. I told him it's on his end. Now it's >> Now
he knows but at the time he didn't. So I had to scream. So you
understood it was an emergency. >> Is it help? Is it help?
He doesn't understand [__] English. >> No,
but you understood to shout quicker at him. >> No. Pegg
Peggy. Peggy. Peggy. You don't understand. I'm only yelling so
you can yell at him and Ty. You're supposed to translate the
yelling. Peggy. Peggy. I'm yelling at you so you yell at him
and Ty. Obviously. Come on. >> It's just annoying me. It
doesn't help me. I understand. You
>> understood to shout at him. Crocodile. He's He's actually
saying this. He actually thinks he's cooking with this argument.
No, I'm only yelling at you cuz I want you to yell at him. >> Yeah,
you understood to shout at him. >> It's just annoying me
when someone talk over me when I'm trying to communicate with
another person on the phone. >> And just so you know, Peggy's
getting paid very good for this. It's not She's not doing She's
not doing
>> I love this one. It's always this one. I did not ask
for it, but she's going to be paid very well for this. It's not
that she does it for free, okay? She's going to be paid extremely
well for this. Okay. Extremely well. >> That I didn't ask
for it. I just asked >> She didn't ask for it, but she
knows that if she does it, she's going to get paid extremely
well. Okay. Just so you
>> So, it's a job that she's doing. >> I quit now.
And you handle it.
>> Okay. I said that's fine.
>> I said that's fine. >> I don't need anything.
I don't need anything. Just pay me back for the ordering IP.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. And you're going to pay me back
for everything, too. You are okay. All right. Let's see how that
works out for you. >> I have money.
>> Yes. The money that I've sent you for the work you've
done for me in the past. What do you mean? You do things, you
work, you help, >> bro. This guy, this guy is inner ch
is just kicking in so hard now. Yeah. The money I sent you in
the p with the streaming and then I the money that I Okay. And
you're going to pay me back for everything, too. Yeah, >> you
are. Okay. All right. Let's see how that works out for me. >> I
have money.
>> Yes. The money that I've sent you for the work you've
done for me in the past. What do you mean? You do things. You
work. You help me with the streaming and then I pay you. That's
just me helping you as well. You help me. I help you. >> I
work it for free. I pay you back. I don't want you to work for
free cuz I'm not an [__]
>> I'm not an [__]
>> I pay you back, you [__] [__]
>> You're going to pay you back every transfer I've ever
sent you. >> She just threw something at him, didn't she?
You see her breaking the camera, you see something rumble and
then she breaks on the camera.
>> I pay you back, you [__] [__]
>> You're going to pay me back every transfer I've ever
sent you. >> Yes, of course. >> All right, go sit
down and add them all >> I still have it. Spoiler alert,
soon. I mean, we're on kick watching a kick stream that's not
from somebody who's banned. I feel like we're probably going
to be fine. I'll disavow. Okay. >> Spend money. >> I'll
disavow. Exactly. You said it, not me. You don't spend money.
You said it, not me. You said it. Not me. >> What? I don't
spend money. >> Yes. Yes. You don't spend money. You said
it again. You don't spend money. >> No. That's why I don't
spend money. >> Yeah. You don't. I don't buy clothes.
>> No, you don't. You don't spend your money. You don't
buy food. You don't pay rent. You don't pay for travel. >> You
want You want to cover that, too? It's fine. >> I do. >> Okay,
then. >> I do cover it. >> The do you mean just cover
it? >> Because I like you and I'm grateful for your help.
And as a man, I don't want you to have to pay for it. >> As
a man, you are you asked for everything back. You >> So,
what exactly is the issue here? This seems so contrived on her
part. unless I miss something. Uh Sam was screaming at her while
she was on the phone trying to tell the security guard what to
do and he's like screaming at the top of his lungs. So much so
that Wes like started laughing and saying he couldn't even understand
what she was saying cuz Sam is screaming at her in the background.
So she didn't like getting screamed at my woman. >> I did
ask for it back. You said you were going to send it back. >> Also,
he made a voice her
bowl so I can see it. >> Okay, fine. Tomorrow. >> It
was a waffle actually. It was a waffle. Man, you are. >> It
was a waffle. >> This is where we got into a fight from
later on. Let's go. >> We've connected. >> It was
a waffle. >> He's gay, by the way. >> I am not gay.
You don't have any proof to say that >> you are because
you asked for everything. You paid for me. You said because I
love you. I pay for you. Now what? You asked me back everything.
You [__] gay. >> I am not a gay.
>> Dude, the silence. She doesn't know how good that is
to let it hang. I am not a gay [__] You [__]
>> Because I love you. I pay for you. Now what? You asked
me back everything. You [__] gay [__]
>> I am not a gay [__] >> Your attitude
as well. Like you're taking girl hormone.
>> Are you happy now? >> Oh, your attitude as well
is like you're taking girl hormone. >> We're finished.
Thank you for your help as well, by the way. I do appreciate
>> Everything, Josh. Everything, N. Thank you for helping
with the security
>> Everything that >> he the reason I the reason
why I want to pay you is because I appreciate
the work you do. I do. I appreciate the work you do and I think
I think you deserve to tell me all the time but one thing I'm
asked for you just to don't >> the attitude that you've
given me just >> but I wasn't in that moment I wasn't giving
you attitude that I communicate with in a day and I want a good
attitude for you
but I'm not just going to shout at like you I'm not going to
shout at you like that in a normal situation. I'm not going to
shower you like that in a normal situation. Two people were about
to kill each other on a show that I'm making on two separate
live streams that's being watched by all of my bosses. And I
was screaming cuz I was worried about the situation. I weren't
screaming cuz I hate you. >> Bro, can can Sam just get
her some food? She still hasn't eaten. It's 10:39. He won't get
her any food. Dude, this these are unreasonable working conditions.
>> I weren't screaming even because anything you've done.
I was screaming because the security guard and I need you to
understand that. That was it. I'm not being a to you. I'm not
being an ass to you. >> And I tell you to stop screaming
because it doesn't help. >> It doesn't help. Just know
that it doesn't [__] help.
>> Don't be stupid. You he doesn't
>> Just me that he help. >> Yes, I know. And I just
wanted you to understand that he needed it was important right
then in that moment. It was bad. I was trying to say you was
bad. You're a good worker. You're always a good worker. I know
you never ask for money from me. The reason why I give you the
money because you work hard on the things you do and I wouldn't
be able to do it without you. I've said the whole time this show,
>> you treat me better. You can't just treat your employee
like and then just hope that they
up until the period we've not argued >> because I didn't
work for you. We just >> Yes, you did. We did. You did
so much for me this month >> for the house. >> But
you never you never gave me attitude sometime like >> Yes.
Because it's not high stress. It's not high stress and high situations.
>> Don't put it on me. Don't [__] put it on
me. >> I'm not trying to put it on you. You know, I'm not
trying to put it on you. It's just when people are trying to
get their job, I'm shouting cuz I'm worried.
Okay. I'm not shouting at you because of you. I'm Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. There's no way.
Did Destiny go on Wick's stream tonight and basically say who's
going to dox Doobie if Doobie didn't [__] off? There's
no shot, right?
There's no shot that that happened. Okay, we might have to We
might have to look at this before I go to sleep. Bro, if Wick
If Wick is that much of a and and Desi go on his show and says
he's going to actually go after Doobie and he doesn't do [__]
I I'm going back to this fight and I'm going to look for that
cuz I'm worried about the situation. Okay. Okay.
>> Okay. You know, I appreciate you. I'm I'm always grateful
of your help. You do a good job. I wouldn't be able to do it
with you. >> Don't worry, we're not going to have a long
stream. I'm not going very far past the timer cuz I'm already
kind of tired. So, give me a second. I'll look this up in the
back. >> I've said it a 100 times on stream. I would not
be able to do it without you. Okay. Is the Sam and Peggy house
done?
>> No, it's your house.
I just want you to >> No, this is the Sam. They're not
even watching the kick house right now. They're watching the
Sam and Peggy
>> they are. We are. Yes, this is the content right now.
>> We're creating better content than they've created in
the whole house the whole time.
Anything with a bit of depth over a
screaming at the same person nonstop. >> I just want sweet
Sam. I don't want >> Yes, I know. But you you you know
during this there's going to be >> Thank you for the time.
I actually found
>> Thank you for the time stamp. Uh I'm going to use the
bathroom real quick before I cover this stuff. I'll be right
back. Okay, but I got it. Thank you. >> All right, get
yourself a rack of ribs. I appreciate you, Peggy. Just know that
I do appreciate you and I'll try.
>> we need we just need to work on the security situation
together. >> Do that thing.
>> Thank you, Peggy.
>> Oh, Jesus.
>> Kick house versus Sam house. >> Yeah, here we
Take Mando as security. >> Here we go. >> Peggy,
please. Sam, half a rack of ribs. >> Oh, I said that. >> Yes,
Peggy. You tell Sam. >> Sammy, how dare you treat me like
It's not my fault you still don't speak Thai. And my [__]
uncle is scared of a rabid giraffe.
Have sympathy. Ah,
>> leave [__] Peggy alone. It's not her fault.
She's running around for you walking on eggshells.
# let Peggy piss. Third day BTW. >> # let Peggy piss. Okay,
Sam, would you just let Peggy have access to a bucket? Okay,
get Peggy a buck. Can someone get Peggy a bucket, please? For
the love of God. is really [__] up.